if we were ranking from 1-32 shireen the
teams that
are most likely to get to the super bowl
in 2021
my guess is the team that would come in
at 32
would be the houston texans and they've
made news again not for
an arrival but for yet another departure
team president jamie roots he's been the
president since the inception of the
team
joined the nfl in 2002 the only
president in houston texans history he
resigned
today this is something that was coming
when the search committee which he was
involved in was ignored
in the quest for a new gm and owner cal
mcnair and
executive vp of football operations jack
easterby went off the board to hire nick
casario
my understanding is roots wanted out
then and there and he was persuaded to
stick around because
there is some degree of self-awareness
believe it or not in the texans
organization regarding the perception of
dysfunction
that has been lingering over the
franchise for the past several months
they didn't want to make it worse by
having roots storm out
justifiably so right after they
disregarded the
project he had spent so much time
working on and hired a guy that wasn't
one of his finalists
so they got him to wait a little while
it wasn't quite a month
and now roots is gone i think this
organization mike owes a lot to jamie
roops and where they've come
frankly from a financial standpoint he's
helped build up this organization bob
mcnair
the late bob mcnair hired him uh lamar
hunt actually was the guy who gave him a
recommendation hired him from a soccer
team
he came in and he built this
organization to one of the most
profitable
in sports history and they're right up
there in the top ten
on the forbes rankings every single year
and jamie roots is a big part of that
and
you know it's just another turnover in
this organization that's gone through so
much since bob mcnair died and you start
to look at the people who are still left
there's not a lot of them mike this is
an organization that's really been
shaken up and
and uh going the wrong way as as we've
said
multiple times now it is a dysfunctional
organization
as mds suggested earlier today on
twitter it's eventually going to be
jackie used to be performing comedy
routines for an audience of one
in cal mcnair and uh look
people continue to ask me what's your
issue with jackie eastwood i don't know
the guy
all i know is he's not qualified to have
the job that he holds
and texans fans should be upset about
that football fans should be upset about
that there are so many more qualified
people
than there are jobs at high levels of
nfl organizations whether it's head
coach
gm executive vp of football operations
there are far more qualified candidates
than there are spots
the idea that someone who is grossly
unqualified would get one of those jobs
is offensive to me it should be
offensive to any football fan
it should be offensive to anyone who
cares about the nfl
collectively because it reflects poorly
on a team and if it reflects poorly on a
team it reflects poorly on the league
and look at where
the texans have gone over the past
several months and the common link
is jack easterby the guy who parlayed
being an
unpaid team chaplain for the kansas city
chiefs nearly a decade ago
into this uncanny climb fueled by
embellishment of his resume fueled by a
game of thrones type of intrigue behind
the scenes where he knows
who to cozy up to and how to potentially
work the angles and build leverage and
force people out
apparently based upon the results i mean
look
he's of all of the departures in houston
over the past six months he's either a
bystander
or he's actively involved i choose to
believe that he's actively involved
no question mike i think he's very
actively evolving
frankly it's not going to surprise me if
they name in the next president of the
organization nothing's going to surprise
me with that organization and where
they're headed
nick casario and david culley might be
great hires
i don't know that they stand a chance
back easter be calling the shots and
it's seemingly that cal mcnair has
picked
jack easterby over deshaun watson that's
the way it looks from the outside from
the inside i don't know
but they're going to have to convince
deshaun watson to come back if that's
what they want and that may be moving on
from jack easterby
which he seems like he's won mike you
would think that the texans would have
already gotten rid of him based on
comments from players and deshaun watson
and it hasn't happened he survived this
and he looks like he's the guy in charge
two points first if he does become the
next president of the team he's even
more insulated from scrutiny
when you have football operations in
your title you're a little too close to
the flame
if things go to hell and i didn't mean
that as any type of a
commentary on you know never mind if
you're the team president
you you are look jamie roots has been
there for 20 years and for most of the
20 years let's face it they've stunk
they've been better in recent years but
when they were horrible from 2002
through 2011 the first year they made
the postseason it wasn't like anyone was
saying well the team president's got to
go
that's a great job to have that's even
better than executive ep of football
operations
from a lack of accountability standpoint
then when things go well
you can you can position yourself for
some
praise and some glory and some adulation
when things go poorly it's not on me
it's on the people in football
operations and i'm not in football
operations so that would be a smart move
for easter b secondly
secondly i'm still not ready to conclude
that the texans will do what is best
for them when it comes to desean watson
and i could see them being
stubborn enough like mike brown was 10
years ago
with carson palmer to say you don't want
to play for us
fine sit and you can sit and you can pay
us back
5.4 million per year in signing bonus
money and you can pay us
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
fines because shireen
we can't have the inmates running the
prison
it's february 10th mike and i'll go on
record as saying right now that that's
what's going to transpire
i would bet i would push all my money
into the middle of the table
having talked to people inside the
organization they are convinced they can
talk desean watson into coming back
even though they haven't talked to just
don't think it's going to happen and i
think they're going to wait too
long for for to try to trade him to
realize that he's really not coming back
they better plan on having another
quarterback option out there
they're convincing to talk him into
coming back if it doesn't happen
and i don't think it's going to happen i
think the bridge has been burned down
they
better have another quarterback option
for this season
and shereen here's what deshaun watson
needs to do and this dovetails with
the item i posted just before the show
began because i think as time passes
we will look back on russell wilson's
interview with dan patrick from
yesterday
as the moment when the evolution of the
nfl tour the nba became a revolution and
quarterbacks
are shedding this company man facade
and speaking and thinking and acting in
their own
interests consequences criticism
scrutiny be damned deshaun watson needs
to sit down with
someone and speak his mind and say what
he wants
because even though we all know what he
wants
he's not going to get what he wants if
he doesn't start putting more pressure
on the team
the kind of pressure that russell wilson
is already putting on the seattle
seahawks he did it
on the final day of the season mike he
said what he wanted
and the texans didn't adhere to that but
now he needs to speak out again because
obviously things have changed because he
didn't get what he want
and having a voice in the gm and the
head coach that didn't happen
so now he needs to speak out again not
speak through his age and not have his
agents speak to other people about what
he wants he needs to talk
and say exactly what he wants and sits
down with the texans and tell them
what he wants himself not coming from
the agent
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports